i was happy to meet daniel because i
said if i do anything on this picture
i'm going to get daniel's autograph we
talked
for a while and kind of you know hit it
off okay
i was comfortable enough to ask him if i
could have his autograph
and he said sure and i said no no
no no no with your left foot
i got it
dances with wolves the buzz was
put out there that this was going to be
wow uh
just a whole new look at the american
west and what happened back then kevin
and his production team had ideas of
making firsts
in terms of like language the kinds of
scenes the story was going to be
all about there was a lot of buzz about
it to begin with
amongst the indians uh native americans
if you will
they said hey man this this thing is set
to
uh be good for us as native americans in
film and there's going to be a lot of
[Applause]
parts
[Music]
let's talk a little bit about your
character known as toughest pawnee
right i had no name right just just the
toughest pony
yeah i had uh a number of people
who were actually pawnee told me
afterwards they either laughed
laughed at me or really appreciated some
parts of the dialogue that i delivered
and so i if i got a small part of it uh
correct then i figured i was floating on
clouds as far as i'm concerned you know
i've done a lot of work in terms of
different
native languages over the years and
being bilingual
has made this something that i can be a
little more
uh comfortable with in that physical
makeup in terms of tongue
mouth all of that that is involved in
speaking
uh is more willing to take chances with
making sounds and
then my mind is at the point that i'm
not going to
feel embarrassed if somebody laughs at
the mistakes i make
avatar avatar
was um demanding of some adjustment for
the actor absolutely nothing changes
other than the fact that you actually
have no
props or uh immediate environment
other than the other actors in the scene
one other physical thing that was at
that time
a bit of an impediment was the fact that
we also wore
helmets with an arm that came around
right in front of our face and it had a
led light
because we had dots all over our faces
as well as
dots all over the rest of our body but
that was something you had to be
kind of uh careful of whenever
you came in kind of close to another
actor
i had the dying scene with nathiri
wherein
she's grieving over the fact that i'm
dying and
i think we may have like clicked those
arms that come out
of the helmet that we wore other than
that absolutely nothing
uh changed in terms of uh what kind of
job we had to do as actors
the navi language i i was happy to have
been included we had both
a linguist and a voice coach to
teach everyone the language and the
meanings of the words that really make
a difference in terms of your
performance what word do you
use the most where do you punch the
dialogue
they asked me to come in in terms of any
ideas that i would have
about the development of a sound
is there a sound like whoosh uh for
something that goes
by or you know how does a language
develop
in terms of making up sounds
that can be shared between people
and they convey meaning i'm amazed at
the fact that there are
so many languages on the face of the
earth right now
that i also feel very unfortunate
and sad for the fact that many of the
languages are uh
are dying or slowly passing from uh
use it was amazing that p afterwards
so many uh fans of the film itself
wanted to learn the language and many
did as
at that point in time mystery man
is very serious man this means he gave
out
advice like you must fight like the wolf
pack
not like the six-pack and
other things that we pulled from uh
the fortune cookie bowl that i got as a
script
uh beginning with those
but yeah mystery men was a great thing
to work on it was actually my first
uh if you will uh comedic part and i
really enjoyed that part of the whole
thing is that oh my god
these people are just absolutely berserk
you know and they're in their ways of
thinking plus it was also like
one of the first wannabe super movies
the super hero movies maybe we're just
we were just a little ahead of our time
or something like that
you're the stinks and you are fools
and i got to meet a lot of uh comic
actors they are very serious people you
know
about their comedy i would sit around on
set
a lot of these guys they would get get
together and start trading
jokes with one another myself i'd be
sitting the table away or something just
kind of eavesdropping and listening and
just bust out laughing at some of the
things that they said
and look over at them and they were
they don't laugh at each other's jokes
but the best compliment they can give
each other is
that's funny you know
i'm so glad you're dedicated to that
because you really make me laugh
last of the mohicans i think a lot of
the credit of course goes to
michael and his producers in terms of
developing the
character of mogwa into a person that
the audience could uh empathize with uh
sympathize with
he definitely served a purpose in terms
of
the overall story of last of the
mohicans were it not for him
you know who else is the uh the danger
lurking in the woods you know it's uh
a matter of developing magwa into uh
uh someone believable the idea was to uh
just play the man like he was in this
in the straits that he was in mogwa took
the hatchet to color with blood
it's still bright only when it's red
then it will be buried
so many sons have said since maguire
struck the
warpost and where is that son
margwa is the son of his people and he
has come to lead
minions we went to the appalachia area
beforehand
and uh trained with a survivalist group
as well as weapons training
old weapons in terms of knives tomahawks
we learned how to use all of those
as well as hand-to-hand uh fighting kind
of things and
it was a lot of training but we had
already started training and gyms
before that you know where we we we had
trainers that came in
even before we went to the survivalist
camp we had started uh working out in
gyms for a couple of weeks and
really bulking up and eating
different diets and it was quite a
[Music]
process
i was happy to meet daniel because i uh
said if i do anything on this picture is
i'm going to get
daniel's autograph when i met him we
talked
for a while and kind of you know hit it
off okay
i was comfortable enough to ask him if i
could have his autograph
and he said sure and i said no no
no no no with your left foot
i got it geronimo and american legend
the experience of playing geronimo was
daunting
there were relatives of geronimo's on
set
and a lot of them were working
background and
or as consultants to certain parts of
either the language and or customs they
all had
varying opinions of him he was
either loved at one end and hated at the
other end
but always seen as a very controversial
figure
he never actually was a war chief
or a fighter of that degree that's not
what he
was known as because he was actually uh
known as a seer as a as a wise man
a guy who knew how to fix things
in terms of the mind as well as the
body he was kind of a you know a
medicine manner he wasn't
the designated warrior that he has
been mythologized as over the years
when their soldiers burnt our villages
we moved to the mountains
when they took our food we ate thorns
when they killed our children we
had more and like i say
he had relatives there who were down to
eight years old
so a person had to be kind of careful at
least i felt like i had to be somewhat
careful in terms of
how i portrayed the man i think uh over
the years i'm still
kind of wondering you know uh exactly
uh how well i did hopefully i served
the purpose of telling his story is all
i can really ask for it you know
street fighter i had never played a
video game in my life and i've only
tried once or twice since then
the real interest in the whole thing was
that i got to work with raul julia
as well as kickboxer trainer vinnie the
jet that's one of the things that really
attracted me to the whole thing
plus it was travel to thailand but to
australia it was quite the adventure i
learned a lot about
other aspects of filmmaking in terms of
where
games and movies meet
you know that was probably one of the
first instances that i had to work with
motion capture we not only shot the film
we also
shot some scenes
uh for the next uh
video game that was to be put together
and do the motions
as i understood it at the time it was
called
motion capture but it was done in
reverse
so our characters had to do everything
from point of impact back to the
beginning
of impact if you were going to hit
something then you had to start from
the point of impact back to where you
started to throw the punch
and then my character had the uh one of
his
skills or powers was the fact that he
threw a box i do
i don't know games all right but anyway
he threw a box
i started from the point of release of
the box
back to getting ready to throw it
right like that and we did that
as well as a bunch of other moves like
kicks and whatever
that the character is known for but uh
yeah that was my
my first experience with some kind of uh
motion capture heat
i in the family had just moved to uh
santa fe at that point in time when i
heard through the grapevine that michael
was doing
a film with de niro and pacino wasn't
too long after
uh mohicans you know so i still had
the office number and i called michael
up talked with his uh desk there and uh
amazingly enough michael hopped on the
phone so
i was kind of surprised but uh anyway he
hopped
on the phone said uh what's going on and
i said
well michael i heard you were making a
film with
pacino dinero and me is that right
there was a long silence and then
he kind of chuckles and he doesn't do
that very much you know very often
but in any case about a week later
i got the call that uh we want to make a
deal here
so uh that's how that all came about
that's right [ __ ] where do we
get him
he's a ci to burglary cop called in the
tip on the back
on neil mccauley how much time we got
eight hours for him to set up a new out
after that he's gone
bye-bye bam what was your experience
working with pacino i enjoyed working
with him and i stole everything uh
i could from him he's a very gracious
man in terms of uh
how do i say that he's a he's very
italian in his
hospitality anytime you want anything
just ask him you know and he he would
ask us
over to his home for uh uh dinners
and uh just hang out like in the
afternoons or something at times and uh
like i say he always had these guys
if you ever need anything just get just
uh get him to
do this or do that but he's very
hospitable uh enjoyed working with
hostiles i think it was a meeting of the
minds
these people had fought each other
before they had been in physical
confrontation it's something that is
inherently strange and uh wonderful
as well as devastating in terms of how
human beings get along you know
soldiers tend to uh elevate
their enemy to a certain extent because
they know that they do exactly what they
they themselves do you know they confer
upon the enemy camaraderie as well
as a great respect for the fact that we
all do this
uh combat together we are involved in a
life or death situation here there's
just something
uh bonding about that
you see he's
i think many soldiers develop great
respect for their enemies perhaps more
so
than the people they actually fight for
i was involved in vietnam and i have a
great respect for the viet cong
not only because of their prowess
their ability to fight their their
guerrillas to the max
and they actually defeated the united
states and i was a part of the u.s army
that was defeated right
but i have a great respect for them not
only for the fact that they are great
warriors
they're probably more like me
than the people i was fighting for you
know
i think that's that was sort of uh what
fed the
kind of feelings that existed between
yellow hawk and bale's character